[Music]
what makes good practice because there
are people who practice a lot they put
in a lot of hours but their skills don't
improve or improve much so what what
makes good practice for you very very
very good question - first of all I say
practice does not make perfect do they
say practice makes perfect
no practice does not make perfect
perfect practice makes perfect
right you can practice something wrong
when you're done it's perfectly wrong
and I see it in my industry all the time
they'll practice a second deal in some
awkward fashion where are the most
common one is a strike second I'll give
a visual clue picture the card is turned
face up on the deck they'll know hold
first of all usually they hold the deck
in real tight what's called a mechanic's
grip a real deep grip and I'll lighten
up the grip a little bit and then when
they go to take the card
they'll bypass the card they've taken is
so they can just hit the second card and
deal it out and and that this tip this
is the standard second do that you'll
see people do well it has all kinds of
tell and has a lot of tone first of all
you're pushing the top card over to
receive it with the other hand so why is
the right thumb bypassing that left them
in this because so they as exposure of
the top of the deck where that second
card is to get a hold of it that is a
totally unnatural action but you'll see
it all the time and then then and that
you don't have a dead deck when
opponent's students and who we came up
here reference was a guy named guitar
Charlie Miller who had the privilege of
spending time with and they grew up all
through the thirties forties 50 60 70 80
80 's and Miller talks about a dead deck
when you're dealing the top card
everything below it there's no movement
and so if there's movement being made
when you're taking the separate card out
and the top card is going back you don't
have a dead deck you have movement of
two different movements there's second
cart coming out the top card going back
now watch my second deal there's the
there's no I'm not crossing the thumbs
at all
and my left thumb is there's no leaking
to the car right at the other other
corner and I'm not going anywhere near
the top of the deck and this that
particular second DUI I have practiced
I've done in front of a live line it's
about five million times and in practice
I've done over a hundred million times
that one move and I i proclaim I said I
say that it's probably the most
difficult move and all of sleight of
hand because there's only two three
other people that are getting it down
and one guys been working on it after he
watched my videos for thirty years now
and there but it just takes a long time
but anybody get off off a track practice
does not make perfect perfect practice
makes perfect
same thing with in the martial arts you
know you saw a sidekick your other
people dose will pick kick up as they go
you lift it and you shoot it in my kit I
come like a blade like as you practice
it wrong you said they're practical and
you're done it's it's not wrong it's
perfectly wrong yeah okay and then and
then there's another thing I like to say
[Music]
discipline breeds discipline they say
how do you put in time and when I'm
telling people and they want to train or
something I say the more you do
something the more you can do have a
discipline breeds discipline you do
something and then the more you're able
to do it and the better you do it and so
and then they say well I just can't run
a marathon
I said don't run a marathon right now I
want you to just walk down the distance
of two houses and walk back make it so
easy
you can't talk yourself online the next
day walk the distance of three houses
come back then the next day jog down the
distance and come back and then
eventually your body starts adapting to
the habit and those endorphins start
getting released and then after a
certain period of time it's like will
you get back in the house does it have
to be a marathon you know how so
discipline breeds this one I love the
perfect practice makes perfect
you